and really I guess the technology ends
up being a combination of multiple
trends or technology developments and so
you've got machine learning you've got
voice recognition you've got some level
of artificial intelligence in there
maybe help us understand like is that a
sequential thing where one technology
gets built that's added to another or
did you have to wait until all of those
technologies reach a certain point and
then you kind of put them all together
and actually get the core of the
technology well all innovation as you
know is nonlinear and so none of it is
ready at the same time that's some some
other function is ready but people like
us don't sit around twiddling our thumbs
waiting for the perfect moment so what
you're doing is you're constantly
iterating and as you know best-of-breed
pieces snap in you go ahead and drop
that module in air your engineers
develop something else you drop that
module in there your scientists develop
something else you drop that module in
there so you may have you know start
with a baseline acoustic model but then
you have a better one that fits the use
cases you may have a baseline language
model you drop in a better one that
supports your use cases whether it was
messaging voice mail processing call
mining a myriad of different use cases
at the time what was funny is as we were
fundraising in the 2007-2008 time frame
for our VC round a lot of people were
scratching their head saying I'm not
sure that I would use an AI assistant
but would you allow my other portfolio
company here I think some examples were
got voice you mail ring ring central and
some others would you allow them access
to your platform and so by default we
ended up becoming this Twilio for speech
recognition for AI services as as an
accidental discovery if you will because
the VCS that we were pitching in some
ways allowed their portfolio companies
to diligence us by becoming customers
yeah that's great when the the people
you're pitching end up doing business
development for you for sure that's
right and so obviously you kind of
describe what you had on the technology
front in 2006 2007 by the time that you
guys actually sold the Amazon what did
the technology do in yeah right like
what have
did you guys get before that acquisition
occurred yeah so prayin which is the new
company's name was actually the codename
of the engine that eventually became a
nucleus of Alexis so we knew that we
needed to have a totally independent
stack because we didn't want you know to
be at the beck and call if you will of
other tech providers so we had a little
bit of a secret mission behind the
scenes and we built a a great research
organization inside of a company which
is not something that you typically find
in a start-up as we were plotting
complete independence and so it was a
state of our speech engine that had you
know some newfangled abilities that even
to this day we can't talk about because
you know a lot of people think that you
invent things and you patent everything
but you typically don't they're the
there are certain core capabilities you
leave as trade secrets for instance
google always was annoyed that they
published PageRank where in hindsight
they wish that they didn't publish
PageRank because it was such a critical
part of of their search acumen yeah that
makes sense
and I guess help us understand in kind
of layman's terms how exactly voice
recognition works right we use it every
day across all these different devices
but what's actually happening when I
verbally verbalize a command or a
question like how does the technology
ingest that and what's going on in the
background before it presents me the
answer yeah the the easiest way for you
to think about that is it's turning
audio files and converting them into
text in order to do that it takes the
audio stream and basically takes
everything that you say and converts it
into phonemes and then it clusters the
phonemes together in in a search to see
hey are these is this the right word for
this combination of phonemes and then it
goes to the next set of photos is this
the right word in the set of phonemes
and then it goes to the third set of
phonemes and says is this the right word
and then you have this concept above by
Graham's tried Graham's quad Graham's
and what have you where it says hey is
this sequence of words together does it
make sense or is there another com
nation of words because every time you
have a word that it identifies it also
has something called an N best meaning
it has a list of alternative words that
it might be right so think of a homonym
like to is a t OT wo or t oo well you
need to know the context before and
afterwards just to figure out which one
it might be yeah it makes a lot of sense
and I guess then one of the limiting
factors to the accuracy is how it in
jest like how clearly can hear the audio
and then the conversion to text and then
what you're talking about here is almost
like the contextual information that
it's able to derive from the other parts
of the sentence right and and and that's
why you know having a great engineering
team paired with a great research team
is so important right because the
research team works on the models and
the engines all the natural language
everything that you think about on the
engineering team we were blissfully
lucky because we had some of the
original folks that worked on the iPod
engineering team worried about our audio
capabilities right our audio stack and
so they were able to find disconnects
where sometimes some of the carriers
that y'all use for your cellular
networks may have had certain devices
recording devices misconfigured that
were constraining the audio quality
which leads to poorer accuracy and so we
had all sorts of routines to cleanse
audio and then unfilled the best
representation of your voice to the
recognizers and the models in order to
have the best accuracy it took Google
about 10 years with all these newfangled
methods that you heard of post-2012 to
catch up to the level of accuracy that
we had 10 years ago that's how tight of
a platform it was